hi Farah I guess Clara can't hear us
hi how are you doing I was trying to
figure out how there you go okay hi
Clara Robert hi Hey hello hello hello
Ellen I do
how are you I'm good
very happy to be here you know great hi
everyone I'm mark hi mark
I think s we can get started
I think we're great are you gonna start
sure okay welcome everybody to our
second link gathering you heard from a
few of us linkers last last week and
really excited that the three of you
could join us this week we had actually
great response when we asked for
volunteers and so we we went with the
first three people that responded yeah
I'm really looking forward to hearing
from from you and and seeing how you use
link and and hopefully helping all of
our audience just learned a little bit
more about link and meet some of our
community maybe I'll pass it over to
Steve to kind of take it from here okay
well I'll just say I'm very happy to see
face to face happy
link and that perhaps there'll be
eventually at this gathering people who
don't use link but who are interested in
language learning
of course I make my videos and I never
see anyone at the other end so this is
an opportunity to see some people which
is fun for me
so with that mark you're in charge as to
who you want to go first and since I
always get a lot of chance to talk I'm
gonna mute my microphone and listen to
what other people have to say yeah I
know I should add one other thing you
know it's very tough right now everyone
is forced to stay at home and we all
nervously look at the news of what's
going on so to keep our minds on
something positive and constructive like
the language burning is good for us not
only keeps us away from thinking about
what's happening but also at the end of
it will end up better in our languages
so I'll pass it back to mark okay yeah
so I think probably what Clara why don't
why don't we start with you you were the
first person that responded on the forum
and maybe introduce yourself tell us
where you are what which language or
languages you're studying and then maybe
explain to us how you you use Linc I
don't know if you any of you are
interested in sharing your screen to
show how you use link but if you if
you'd like to there should be a share
screen option on the bottom of your
window so when you're ready click share
screen and and take it away and and if
you have any issues just just let me
know but yeah Clara please the floor is
yours all right first of all thank you
for having me and I prepared a little
bit of stuff here in my screen so I'm
just gonna share it with you but first
of all just to introduce myself my name
is Clara I come from Italy central Italy
so near Florence about an hour away and
for both in my work and private life I
use six foreign languages on a daily
basis almost apart from English it's
going to be basically Russian Japanese
Korean Spanish Portuguese etc but right
now I'm trying to get
to a pretty good level in Korean so I'm
just gonna show you how you use link for
me in order to improve my Korean because
I've managed to have a lot of Korean
friends right now so I'm trying to have
try to have meaningful conversations
with them basically so one thing I
wanted to show you is that is how I use
link in order to do two things which is
basically what Steve talks about a lot
which is learning the big picture versus
learning the nuts and bolts the little
bits and pieces of the language so I
wanted to show you how you sling for
both of these things so let me just try
to share there we go
here we have my screen I don't know if
you can see it yep alright awesome so
I'm a huge fan of learning through
YouTube learning languages because
that's how I learned English in the
first place and I've managed to learn
different languages with that as well so
I'm trying to do it with Korean a lot of
people say it's not easy to find Korean
videos with subtitles but as you can see
here I've got a playlist with things of
interest I've got about 400 videos so
that's a lot of learning and that's a
lot of learning it's gonna take me more
than a year to go through all of this
but these are not of course videos that
I've chosen like willy-nilly just going
on YouTube these are videos that are in
line with my interests so just gonna
share you this one here just to give you
an example for people who don't know how
to import YouTube but you see here we
got the Korean subtitles but you have
actually Japanese English whatever so
these videos are awesome to use for
learning and then you can go ahead here
and import and port them onto link you
see here everything's done Korean you
can choose course you want to put it in
and you're done just to give you an
example and there you go we're here this
is a lesson of made from a YouTube video
talking about single mothers in Korea so
there you go what I like to do is I like
to study it in sentence
mode because I have the video on here
and the cool thing is that I like to
link while watching the video because
the visual cues that I get are really
good for me to actually guess the
meanings of words and stuff like that so
I like to have this help as well while
I'm listening and that's how I do it
another cool thing is that if you go
here now this is an Italian but you can
see like edit lesson you could
technically if you have YouTube videos
in your target language and English as
well you could technically put the
English translation by editing here
going on clips there you go translation
English you could technically copy and
paste the translation I do this
sometimes for videos they're a little
bit too difficult for me in my stage so
I like to have a little bit of help any
help that I can get is good so just to
give you an example of how you could do
it for this video you see here these
little three dots there you go open
transaction and you have the English so
you can do this on YouTube as well but I
like to do it on link of course because
I can save words and phrases etc and you
can go here copy paste it over there
save it and then you have it and a
little example is this I've got another
lesson here if you go on sentence vote
and you tap here there you go I have the
English translation which always helps
me instead of having a Google Translate
sentence which can be good sometimes but
when you're a little bit confused about
certain types of like syntax and grammar
can be of help using the English
translation since it's you know it's
available and this is for the big
picture so I like to use YouTube videos
a lot even though my Korean stage is not
at a level where I can understand them
and enjoy them as much as I do with
English videos but that's good
since I like the videos and I like to
watch them and listen to them that's
good now for another thing is that you
can also use this website here which is
called Korean 0 2 here you can use it
for English Chinese bunch of languages
and the cool thing that this site does
is that if you let's try to put like I
don't know a random word but let's try
to see if it's good well it got another
ward but anyways what you do is that you
type a word in here and they give you
YouTube videos related to the word that
you're looking for and if you tap here
they gave you the basically the English
translation and Korean in my case closed
caption if available so if you want to
speed up your YouTube subtitles process
then you can go here now for the nuts
and bolts I never do the review here
because I hate flesh cards and I hate
being tested on stuff I have like trauma
from back in the day at University
studying Japanese and having like a huge
Anki deck of stuff trying to memorize
all the kanji and I honestly I hate it
so if I'm sometimes if I'm a little bit
confused about some grammar points in
Korean which is a highly nuanced
language and stuff they have lots of
little endings they put on stuff what I
like to do when I get curious about one
of these what I do is that I use a lot
of tags and I use the notes section on
the flashcards so instead of doing the
review like this I like to filter over
here and it got a bunch of filters I can
give you an example this one's good
there you go
so these are all words and phrases that
I saved the
have this kind of pattern here this kind
of pattern is a pattern I've been
confused about for some time so what I
do is that a while I'm reading if I'm
confused about something I just get the
pattern google it and then start to save
everything I see with that pattern and
then while while I'm reading if again I
see that I'm getting a little bit
confused or not too sure about this kind
of pattern this mind you is like five
percent of my time ninety five percent
is reading listening and everything like
that but five percent of my time is
actually filtering stuff and then this
way with this window here instead of
doing the review I can actually see how
the words change with that pattern I can
see the translations and I can see all
the sentences here so that I get them in
context and then if we try to click on
not maybe no there you go
you see here in the notes that I've
pasted something from the internet that
I found about that particular pattern so
what I like to do instead of review I
like to just see the phrases see the
context they're in and then go into some
of them and eventually I'll find if I'm
still confused I'll find some
explanations that have pasted over here
and that's it great all right great
great I asked you a question go ahead
and also you share my prejudices when it
comes to language learning where do you
find all those Korean videos is that
something you could share with us not
necessarily today but a farmer or even
today is a toughy and it's tough finding
good content and you've got a treasure
trove I'd be very interested I'm not
doing Korean right now maybe we could
gather the the links together maybe at
the
and paste some in the form or maybe in
the yeah this this video will go up on
YouTube so maybe we can paste some stuff
there I don't we'll figure out where we
can I can post it as well I mean like
I've got tons of resources actually so I
can you know I can share them no problem
and website that that lets you search
for you know it to you again
let me show it to you again
basically this I found it I don't
remember if it was on YouTube on reddit
but basically there you go this website
here is actually a Canadian website and
it was built from a guy and he has it
let me show you again because this is
pretty interesting they've got tons of
languages I haven't tried for other
languages if it works if it doesn't work
but I I think it's gonna be working but
let me show you again when you go to the
dictionary now this the website is
called Korean zero to hero it's not easy
to find if you just google it so I would
recommend you to just go ko zero to hero
CA and just find it like this
but if you go to the dictionary ah you
see it's working or not let me try again
with it with an easier ward it was
trying hang up and see if it comes up oh
there you go
it's giving me random words I don't know
why but basically let's try with this
maybe actually this one so basically you
click there you go you click on the
YouTube video that is connected to the
word that you're looking for and it
gives you the subtitles in this case
it's Korean and it gives you the English
so what this does and the interesting
thing is basically if you work with
topics so let's say that you like
I don't know fishing and you want to
learn about fishing in Korean then you
would go to this website just write
fishing you'll get tons of YouTube
videos connected to that topic and then
you just click on one and see yours
you'll see here these subtitles if they
have the closed caption subtitles
otherwise you have like an error message
saying sorry this YouTube video doesn't
provide subtitles and stuff like that
when you do what it my process is
basically extremely easy I try to create
on YouTube a sort of feed so I want to
let YouTube understand that I like
videos with Korean subtitles closed
captions how I do this is basically
first stage as I go on to this website
and I just write a random word of a
topic I'm interested in and I find a
couple of YouTube videos with subtitles
then what I do next is I have here I
created on YouTube boom it's self
explanatory Korean CC playlist so what I
do whenever I find a video like this I
would go into the YouTube channel and
see if they have other videos with
subtitles because sometimes they do and
I would save each one of them so I'm
creating this sort of self created feed
then what you do is you look for other
channels related channels and usually
YouTube starts to understand that you
like that kind ask a question in the
Clara there was a question from Justin
does this only pull videos with pre-made
subtitles or also ones with Auto created
sometimes no it it doesn't count Auto
created subtitles it only counts
self-made subtitles now the word Korean
another tip you can see here I can show
you there's this Jim make this called
Korean Jim make now Jim make is
basically a Korean startup and what they
do is that they offer subtitle work to
YouTube creators so basically a Korean
vlogger you
is this startup so that they can provide
him the subtitles
usually in Korean English and tons of
other languages so I like to look for
this for Korean specifically because you
have the Korean and then always you're
gonna have English and then you have
gonna have a bunch of other languages
and I've noticed that this startup the
the English subtitles are pretty pretty
good not native level I would say but
pretty good so you can use them no
problem and a couple of channels I can
recommend you this one here that you see
here this young tongue TB is basically a
TV channel with North Korean defectors
who live in South Korea and they talk
about their experiences just I think
marks suggestion of leaving links in the
description box might be a good
otherwise yeah yeah and not everyone's
into Korean but this is amazing like if
I had seen this when I was doing Korean
that we just have you know accelerated
my learning I struggle with finding good
stuff in Korea and that's why I gave up
Korea and went to Russia anyway the
thing is that I think in every language
if you know how to do it like if you
learn how to create a self-created feed
on YouTube you're you're gonna have the
reading and listening material
absolutely that's what it's all about
okay great I'm sure there are questions
I mean there's well I picked up the few
that came through on some that I saw on
the QA okay we have some stuff in
YouTube that was a great presentation by
the way Clara that's amazing yeah it's
amazing amazing
[Music]
someone's asking when will met the
Netflix imports start working on chrome
again it is working on chrome again just
make sure that you have the latest
version of the extension installed there
was a period there where
a chrome had our extension on in their
review process which took forever so
that we asked people to download the
extension from our site directly but now
you can go back to the chrome store and
download the extension from there it
should be working properly again with
YouTube with Netflix everywhere yeah and
we have a few questions for Steve but I
think we'll just save those for later or
another time someone's asking I know
videos people import into link become
shared in the feed but is there a way to
view all video links that have been
publicly imported this would be a good
feature only important lessons that
users like and which have an original
URL actually will show up in the feed so
most videos that users import will not
show up in the feed unless you'd like so
if you like your if you import a YouTube
video think is great and you like that
video it will actually show up for other
users which is kind of good to know but
otherwise we can't really share
everybody's videos in the feed unless
they give us permission so that's
probably unlikely to happen but we are
working on a way to in our new version
of the library where we will be
recommending sources of content to help
people who aren't as able as Clara to
find great content on their own okay
well that's great
Clara thanks very much super interesting
I can't wait to try that zero to hero
website out myself
Robert how about you maybe you could
follow up with with how you use link
okay hey hi once again I hope I don't
stutter in the middle of my lil ramble
well first of all my name's Robert and I
live in Chelyabinsk there is a city
located in the in the in the southern
part of Russia so I am 19 I study at
University
and right now I'm learning English a
little bit of French and also Chinese
Mandarin so right now I'm gonna show you
my screen well can you see it
yep okay well first of all I would like
to start with English still I started
learning English a couple of years ago
so I have made a lot of progress since
there is thanks to Steve Kaufman I
watched a lot of his videos and I was
really inspired by their well as you can
see I have various 30,000 words know in
English and mostly I read and listen so
as you can see I have a couple of things
here that I'm currently reading there is
a selection from the discourses of
epictetus Sons and Lovers and recently I
finished down and out in Paris in London
so well there is nothing new Under the
Sun and since I have been watching
videos of Steve quite a lot so basically
how I learn languages is through method
well let me show you my stats
yeahlet's well as you can see I mostly
read and listen when it comes to
speaking I don't speak a lot I mean as
you can hear because my accent isn't
very good but well and what I want to
say is that a lot of people stumble when
it comes to going through the place that
is also known the lot oh well that's for
example when they are going through a
period from b2 to c1
well I don't exactly would say that I am
it's beat soon level but all I want to
say he is for English learners out there
I would recommend some things for
example a site called Project Gutenberg
where you can find a lot of the books
for example this that's very helpful and
you can import them in tooling and
studied there also I would recommend a
site called playing its people it also
has a lot of books in English here we go
well from English I would look to change
to Chinese so at university I study
Chinese Mandarin and right now I'm
having a problem and that problem is
like many of you know and when you first
or any language you don't have any
chance to listen or reads interesting
content there is a big problem so what I
do is I listened ministeries at link so
that helps very much and I add them to
my playlist and listens on my phone when
I for example wash my dishes or
something
doing work around home I mean and you
know the biggest problem that I have
right now is that I'm in that stage
where I cannot listen or read to
interesting content so I haven't found
anything that would interest me really
so what's like I said there is a problem
that many people face so what what I
would love to share with you is that
first of all in order to achieve success
in language learning you have to find
content that is interesting for you so
without that you won't succeed in any
way like I'm having a problem right now
with my changes but to give you an
example in my group at university I do
better than most of my classmates and
that's thanks to link because as you can
see traditional ways of learning another
language are not working
so the main thing is inputs and you have
to put a lot of time listening and
reading in order to have some base and
many people worry about speaking and
what I would say to them is that when it
comes to speaking you don't have to
worry about it just read and listen I
think my my way of learning language is
very reminiscent of Steve Kaufman or
stephen krashen or poor of the matter so
yeah thank you for giving me time to
share my thoughts yeah great thanks very
much Robert and yeah your English is
great I don't you don't be bashful
it's resident
comment a bit about the inner funny
content in Chinese and that whole issue
of getting from the many stories to
interesting content okay so yeah well
that's that's great nice to hear that
that you're obviously doing better than
the rest of your classmates and at
university in Chinese I have no doubt
that's true I guess we should let's see
what the kind of questions were getting
before moving on see if there are any
let's see
yeah I guess yeah maybe I think again
why don't we just deal with it at the
end that's probably best we have some
people gathering those questions so
we'll save them towards the end and then
we can we can all participate in
answering questions so so why don't we
move on to Francisco next and maybe
again please zhenya tell us where you
are and what you're doing with link okay
thank you thank you thank you so much
for this conversation for this
opportunity to meet to discuss well I am
Francisco I am from Spain I am a
professor of the other University here
in Granada I am I am in lockdown right
now very hard one of that I go out once
a week for groceries and that's it
and we can solve the situation's here to
improve will help we hope it will be as
soon and well you know here you know how
it is going so it's a Burberry it's very
very nice to get to talk with you and
discuss on I'll still I still said to
think about other things okay so a
little bit of background before I show
my screen here well I well I I am very
passionate about languages how I began
learning languages but back in the day
there was no length that no internet
sorry Hey
very few possibilities to get material
and so on and the funny thing is that a
bit by myself I discovered say I
discover a method which is similar to
the one that [ __ ] crashing researched
the one that that link proposes because
I really found out that I really wanted
to to learn languages and was very hard
at school so I I guess got some some
novels but in the beginning were of
nothing French from my from my father I
think I just tried to understand it was
very hard very very hard but you do
learn you do learn you try you learn and
this may approach really and there even
remember when I was trained to learn
some Latin that I found a program back
in the day in which there was the
and the worrying that they were in
France by Judas scissor but you could
click on that on there on the words and
get a translation and therefore that's
wonderful
this belittle been what were tell and
Link offers and hung asteroids let's say
because it has to make so many more
features this may approach really to to
to a language learning and what I like
to share with you today is that is there
a general approach because link run the
links my main to say my main Kings my
mighty tool in learning languages but
there's still thinking that we need a
like a strategies you know the strategy
English links it in in general I like to
share my my own in case it it is helpful
and for this for this I will I will
share my screen because right now let me
see okay here it is over here and I
think it's interesting because well I'm
I'm addicted to link really so I double
in lots of languages really I love some
Norwegian where they went to Oslo and
then for Christmas when I could I could
still travel and I are really a double
in lots of languages but right now I
think it's interesting because I am
beginning anyone I'm locked down so I
will take the opportunity to learn which
is Japanese and there's another one
which is the matter which has been my
main target for a long time with Russian
so I I'll try to show a little bit how I
learned in the beginning how learn when
I when I already have some level in
general and well and for Japanese well
the best it's great because when I
started Russian I didn't know link so I
did a couple of things that really made
me lost time now I'm learning the way I
think I like learning and what I do is
like I said you know Lestrade I I do use
I like knowing about language
I know lower and knowing how the
language works and how what makes the
language stick and for that I use I use
books okay and I one thing I like a lot
Samael okay so I do use the female
Japanese of the mill I used in French
school gathering okay I get to to brush
up on my friends as I learned Japanese
and before I think I just did that
that's good great on the other hand is
very very frustrating because there's so
many words that you you don't you can't
learn and as a mill the book act as if
you really could learn and you can't
really count right now I still use as a
mill I think it makes me it gives a very
good introduction to the language it
makes me a burn less the grammar or
rules or whatever but I don't wait to
finish I I dive into link at the same
time and and I trust a link to learn
vocabulary for real because the way I
learned vocabulary is just like a mayor
possibility minimalist really for
example in Japanese name language that
I'm beginning right now real this very
minimalistic what I do is I find
something that I like I I agree with
Robert well he said get in finding
something that interesting is paramount
so what I do is sort of like stories and
not not simple stories for example lay
many stories I do use them but it's not
my cup of tea really but like a story
that really and but I really can get
into really get interested in what I'm
beginning I've been very happy because
there's a couple hearing a link and I am
I
I think the collaborators that that
uploaded the stores for example right
now I really in this thanks for long and
this is storage called you came on Yuki
no monogatari it's the yoga story and
this interesting because it's very
simple but it has medias in it has
princesses and so on so it really it
only helps you a lot in the beginning
and the idea group was with Clara that
when I be in this kind of languages
nothing else that's a Russian for
example but in Japanese I guess in Korea
as well
I I do use their the sentence view link
for the song I don't know you can you
can read my page like this will you
covered by something's and what your
beginning in a language such as Japanese
a lot because understand the structure
of the sentence is important so I have 9
my center here and I tried to understand
the structure what is it all about and
and and I go on and make and make
something it's ain't very often once I'm
honest know what something is all about
I do translate the sentence because I
still good it makes me put on the
beginning best me see if I understood
the structure correctly and well in
general now we'll go back to or not now
to Russian because the day is now but
the Cabal phase of the Japanese in
general my approach in afro level is
like this what I what they think is this
I think well this is our story and I
like this story it's about princesses
the Bosnian I like it so what I try to
do is yeah let's say decipher the story
I want to know what the story is all
about and that's it that's my that's my
understanding or the way I think about
comprehensible input it's like I have a
message may be written may be spoken and
they want to know what this all about
because you don't know the language very
very well
you have to decipher it I have to make
an effort and there are some some words
some part that help you because you know
them because you you can kind of guess
for them in like this for example the
Yuki here your kids is there is the name
of the heroine of the story the main
also snow I know that I know that so
it's a it's a word of healthy if it
helps me I declare it known as unknown
word for me because they help them you
understand and there are words that I
don't that don't help me because I don't
understand them and this I have to look
them up your a link links make up it
makes this very very easy and because
this is not helping really I make a link
visit that general approach is very
simple very simple very minimalistic as
I say
and that's what I do I tried to read
interesting things at the same time as I
mean I I have a look at some information
above language and I try to decipher the
message then I listen and when I listen
a bit the same thing with him when I am
beginning okay here I don't understand
very much so I just tried to follow I
already read a story and I was to follow
when the story I am something's helped
me so he don't help this is what they do
her for a long time really
and I alternate between stories and
between some information about language
in the language itself of the lessons
about grammar and so on see what I'm
doing Japanese because I just start
there really a thing I'd like to show
you about Russian because this shows the
other levels once you most of the
understand the language when you're
better the language so we'll show you my
approach and Russian the other thing is
that is a progress in the language what
I try to do is really go to a native
content as soon as I can really and
that's the heart River how do you get to
knitted computers but we're really a
link really helps because because link
helps you rate and understand things
that are much beyond your level that
would be very very hard to you don't the
skin on your own and it really really
helps I think what they do little by
little is I go on to more complicated
lessons for a while I do I do go back to
two lessons and to intermediate listen
all the time but as soon as I can I move
on to native content and as I move up to
native content I do use YouTube as Cora
does but I do it Edward as we were
differently here there is a time where I
tried to split what I read and what I
listen to so for a while I have the
transcripts I have the lessons and they
listen to the same things that I read
as soon as I can I tried to stop doing
that I tried to to read a link and
whatever it is novels that's right - I
start to want to read novels as long as
I can because I like novels because I
think they give a lots and lots and lots
of vocabulary because I do I do read
novels in in there that were written
originally in the language so they
helped me understand both the culture as
well
so here and a lot of the companies come
to contact that I upload to link I still
I still go to the n-terminal lesson like
if again if again your lessons and
Russia which are very good but III will
try to to move to me to a native
language to live content and for example
over here and there is a lot a lot of
notes a Russian a link lots of them some
of them quite difficult really
it would have been very difficult to
understand at that level in on my own
what a few simple thing are Soviets are
safe I like some of them a couple of
dance over here
Oriol I read the only exception to the
rule that I read content in everything
in the original language is Buddha kami
adalah Britannia Russian as well and
they've read Master and Margarita is a
wonderful wonderful novel books so
difficult that could really good could
we okay thanks to thanks to link again
and I've read this this series which is
very interesting for me it's a it's a
series of Russia bestseller got cotton
is happy like read change and this is
like a thrillers and and a bit of
fantasy but in the in a modern setting
is in Petersburg with a bit of humor
I've read some talk some Tolstoy I I've
still reading really warm piece because
it's so big so little by little I still
I still read read some lesson some
intermediate lessons but I really try to
get to native content and that really
try to read I use link mostly to rate
and as for listening what they do is I
go to youtube but a try to find things
that they can understand without
subtitles
and I I try to do that very rather soon
it's my own approach why do I do that
it's because I think there's a tendency
for us of learners to get hooked on the
idea that you have to understand
everything every every single word it
because we have not a transcript and we
have our audio we get used to that and I
like I really like to train myself
during my brain
to a situation where you really don't
understand everything but you can as I
said it's a like a deciphering of the
message but you can follow the story and
you do that by steps I do use some
subtitles sometimes yeah there are
subtitles in only but channels that I
will show you one of them tells the type
that are for learners like I like a lot
this this channel Russian with Max and
that you have subtitle and address
crucial link and so on but at the same
time I try to find real content I begin
abortion at the beginning this is the
beginning in the beginning I what I what
works for me is that I find videos about
activities that I like because I know
something about that are physical and
because I know some of the language I've
already been having a link I try I like
a lot of this work for example it is
about that was kidding it's getting on
ice for for beginners I like that a lot
and I found that and I am I could
understand most of the things part of it
I understand because I know the words
because I've been studying for I don't
know maybe a few month part of is
because I see it and part of it because
I anticipate what's going to happen and
this is my approach to comprehensible
input and for a long long time I do this
is what I do
i-i-i-i I listened to some external link
but they mostly read novels a link and I
tried to get vocabulary there and then I
try to understand this kind of this kind
of things I begin with this kind of
videos a very physical with a lot of
context I think I graduate to more
complicated work little by little and I
end up watching series or films or
things like that it once I have a good
understanding I began talking and I I
tried to go an immersion I've been in
Russia for a couple of times in
immersive experiences last time was very
interesting because I was on a tour in
kayak and on a Laker Russia there's
everybody who heard Russia's around me
and they were very curious how I how I
golurk aqui aqui double and so on and
this is him this the last the Nautilus
really but this is this is one of them
let's say of the all the things that I
work towards really get interim work but
before that it takes very long this
really in rushing of being I've been at
home for a few years now this this is
more or less their their material
approach to language learning and ASL
link really bridges there then there's
this gap between between a beginner
level and irrelevant what you can really
understand native content which is very
very very difficult this mean for me
this is the most difficult part the
hardest part in language learning and
that's what time you link the far okay
it's everything
thank you great well thanks very much
Francisco that was a very interesting I
how's your skating must be pretty good
if you're watching all those videos I
like skating okay we might unshare the
screen so that we can see okay yeah
anyway that's pretty much so there were
a couple questions there first of all
let's see Francisco someone's asking
what your preferred sites are for
finding novels important part in my own
in my own process and it really depends
on the language for Russia for us and
it's easy because there is a there are a
couple of online book shops especially
in liters well you can get very very
cheap books and there is no DRM no
protection whatsoever so you get your
you'll get your file and your potential
link and that's wonderful
sometimes I do get for
public domain because I said I already
read what what a bit one piece and that
I got from public domain but I said to
that problem language gets bought it
gets more complicated so I really I
really have to look for either I get
nervous for an apology men tend to be
old or i or or really have to to find an
online and another book shop where you
wait you don't have protection for that
for the books and that's complicated
that's what a proponent they have for
sampling Indonesian to learn a language
that I'm I'm trying to to learn it's
very hard to find good yeah I was gonna
say I'm prepared to put all the things
that I've used for polish and for check
and for like Russian for example put up
all the links that I use if we can all
put up the different links that we use
different resources where we find books
many people watching you know it might
be fun if we could collect in the
comment section to this video just a
whole bunch of links or maybe even on
the on our forum at link we have done
this in the past but we should perhaps
do it again because it gets read yeah
okay or in either place okay I mean I
think there are some more questions here
[Music]
some of them are sort of more general
not necessarily targeting our speakers
so then yeah maybe that maybe the next
thing but what Steve why don't you be
give a little yeah point just to say
yeah yeah I mean I think all of us are
learning in more or less the same way
and of course we are keen language
learners now there are some people who
are not so confident so experienced all
right I must say that Robert for you to
say that you've been learning it for two
years your English is phenomenal
phenomenal North Thunder weather six
thing which is
francisco who bounces from Japanese to
Russia to Indonesian I mean we are the
Keener's right a lot of people are less
confident and we all touched on some of
the same issues like how do we get
started well I have fall in love with
many stories as a as an approach I spent
yesterday and today I was doing a lot of
cleaning house because after all they
got nothing else to do right so cleaning
house if I would listen to hours
yesterday to hours
know yesterday and the day before do the
mini stories and then just in in
Levantine Arabic now because I want to
get some sense of the differences
because even when I listen to Standard
Arabic there either use like colloquial
Arabic in there and I don't know what
they're saying so I listen to for four
hours at Levantine Arabic and I was
reminded of what this this book I often
referred to Manfred Spitzer where he
talks about how the brain learns and
basically by the first year of its life
a baby has heard and is familiar with
most of the structures in their native
language and if they had to rely on
being taught these structures in the
classroom the way we teach foreign
languages most people couldn't speak
their native languages so that and so
I'm listening Dulles Levantine Arabic
and I'm getting a sense of Levantine
Arabic I can't necessarily understand
every word but I'm getting a sense of
the structure in which again related to
what Francisco said about listening to
things that he doesn't fully understand
and it's important to eat too and I've
criticized this tendency and language
instruction to ask comprehension
questions like did you understand and my
reaction always is is none of your
business with our understand but make be
understood that half like that whatever
I understood was good for me and the
child is the same way the child doesn't
understand everything and it doesn't
identify all the structures challenge us
to accept what they understand and the
rest just flies by them and that's ok
too so I think this idea that we we
gotta obviously have to good language
learners live with uncertainty not
understanding it doesn't matter whatever
we get is good but we miss is too bad
and so you know many stories I think are
good in that sense and then we all want
to progress to where we can get to the
really good stuff that we enjoy and
again I agree with Francisco I mean as
he meal promises that with the
one little book you're gonna get the b2
are you joking
you know what I mean you're not even
close because to be at V to be 2 you
have to consume so much of a language so
much of the language and and what they
offer you in SME lists maybe 3 hours or
whatever it is and of course the the
ramp up is phenomenal for the first 30
40 lessons is very easy and other than
whoop but don't understand anything
anymore so no but they have to sell
their books so it's a long road as
someone said that Plateau there's even a
pre plateau which is kind of where where
I am where I can't really understand my
Arabic podcast very well and so hard to
get a toehold because there's so many
new words and and it's tough and you
just have to keep doing it but one of
the things again that the metric spitzer
said was whenever we exceed our
expectations the brain gets a bit of a
dopamine tick so maybe we should keep
our expectations down or something or at
least recognize that when you understand
something that you didn't understand
before that's good and and on the other
hand he also says you know we talk about
motivation part of the problem is that
we are naturally motivated the brain
wants to learn we are naturally
motivated and yet we do things to
demotivate us and and amongst those is
all these drills and questions where you
know I gotta have I bought this book for
Egyptian Arabic and chapter one they
show you a picture of you know of a
teapot and you know a cat or whatever
they think you should learn and on
chapter one and then right away they
want to test you on it you know they
show you a picture of a teapot and a
word it's just right like I'm gonna get
them wrong it's very demotivating to do
all this stuff so what what we do I
think all of us here and hopefully
people use link is trying to have
activities that give you a sense of
achievement and satisfaction oh and one
other thing I was going to share with
you is is Spencer points out that the
brain likes novelty and I've mentioned
this before so I always find that I do
less than one like I started in a
Persian or Arabic lesson one I don't
understand a thing I've looked a few
raise up I still don't understand it and
then I want to go to lesson two
I still haven't learned lesson one but I
want to go to lesson two the brain likes
novelty so even if I don't understand it
I want to go to something new I don't
want to stay you know pounding my head
against this you know story that I just
don't understand I'd rather not
understand another story because it's
new so I think those are some of the
things that our brain likes to do and
that we should do and that go against
the traditional approach that you have
to master this way and you can't move
forward until you have mastered this and
of course we don't master it I took some
notes here again on
yeah I'm this other one thing that I
found very good in Persian is that I
found this collaborator in Iran who is
she just tell stories about herself and
what she did and she traveled in India
and now she's also producing a history
of Iran in her own words
very simply narrated and so I happen to
be interested in history so this is kind
of like the pre plateau this is not yet
a podcast it's something that that kind
of slides you away from the many stories
towards perhaps being able to eventually
access something more seriously and I'm
often you know wish that that if we can
get this kind of content in Chinese for
example I was lucky when I studied
Chinese that we had a simplified history
of China so I'm always interested in in
in history so to me that was interesting
but if we can get people to talk
naturally and then transcribe but talk
naturally about things that might be of
interest to people that could be a step
towards that so basically yeah that's
kind of what I had to say here yeah
basically that I'm very impressed with
the three of you I'm amazed at how you
know creative you are and finding ways
to learn oh and I should say Robert
Canadians know Shelley elites because we
know there's a hockey team they're
called tractor jelly beans yeah so
most people have never heard of
Chelyabinsk but in Canada we've heard of
tell you anyway so great in session and
I think we got to do this some more and
get other people to participate
absolutely yeah great well I think with
that maybe we'll we'll wrap things up I
know we had other people anxious to
speak but we'll try to fit you in in a
future yeah we can go to different time
zones and so that yeah being in four
people in different parts of the world
sure okay thank you thank you very much
okay thank you and stay safe everybody